i've been saying for a number of years
that all
roads lead to narcissism and for the
people i know
who vote that way they voted that way
and they want to kind of will themselves
to be correct because
his ostensibly what you're saying is is
you're democrat yes you vote democrat
yes then you're responsible for gavin
newsom
and garcetti yes well then you're wrong
the next thing you can say is you're
wrong you're wrong and these are people
that
hate being wrong they have huge egos and
they never want to be wrong
so it's like a kind of a cognitive
dissonance it's kind of like
yeah i voted for that guy and yeah
he's doing a horrible job but i'm going
to vote for that party again
because that way i'll never have to
admit i was wrong but you are wrong
because they're running the state into
the ocean
there aren't that many public people in
cali that are really publicly
fighting the lockdowns and trying to get
people back to work your whole
your whole sort of public existence is
sort of based around
the value of work and and your story
about work and you like
you like people that work basically you
see value in work
what do you what's your take on just
nobody's working
i mean we got companies with people
working thankfully but
a lot of people aren't working you know
i think
the the problem it's it's kind of a it's
a
leftist democrat sort of mindset
which is why do you work and the answer
is
to get money to buy food to take care of
your family to pay rent
okay well what if we just paid your rent
and gave you food and it's like well
that would
seem to handle the problem
mathematically
at first glance but you're forgetting
about a super important part of work
which is
self-worth and pride and self-esteem and
the depression that kicks in
and all that once you get on the dole so
their thing
is they have this bizarre approach to
reverse
engineer everything like hey if if a lot
of young black
teens are being suspended from schools
then stop suspending young black teeth
it's like okay
that's not going to fix anything if if
homelessness is illegal then don't make
it illegal anymore like this
and gastonis that way too it's like the
prisons are overcrowded
how do we fix that let everyone out of
prison
well that obviously doesn't fix you know
the
75 of the kids can't do uh math at grade
level well then lower the test scores
it's like okay your car's not going fast
enough
well then bust the glass of the
speedometer and take your finger
and turn the needle up to 80 miles an
hour you're still going 23 miles
why is it though i think i've asked you
this publicly on the show last time and
i know we've talked about it privately
why is it though that so many people
cannot
make the jump from the stupid decisions
to their involvement in the stupid
decisions that no matter how many times
they vote in people and policies that
make everything worse like
right now if you and i walked out of our
studios and we just started talking to
people on the street and you said to
people how's it going in l.a
everybody would say man it's a freaking
mess or if you said
how's gavin newsom doing they'd all say
horrible no there's nobody defending
these people at the you know i get
there's the rabid
sort of crazies but pretty much nobody
else but why is it
and is it is it just because of the
weather it has fried all of
our brains basically it's nice out so
people cannot
realize that the stupid easy answers
aren't
the actual answers i've been saying for
a number of years that
all roads lead to narcissism and for the
people i know
who vote that way they voted that way
and they want to kind of will themselves
to be correct because
his ostensibly what you're saying is is
you're democrat yes you vote democrat
yes then you're responsible for gavin
newsom and garcetti
yes well then you're wrong the next
thing you can say is you're wrong
you're wrong and these are people that
hate being wrong they have huge egos and
they never want to be wrong
so it's like a kind of a cognitive
dissonance it's kind of like
yeah i voted for that guy and yeah
he's doing a horrible job but i'm going
to vote for that party again
because that way i'll never have to
admit i was wrong but you are wrong
because they're running the state
into the ocean the state has no money
there's homeless people everywhere drug
addicts our education's horrible do you
think maybe we should try voting for
somebody else
did you see when uh uh who was it um
bill maher had adam chiffon and mars
complaining mars going oh all of my
friends are leaving la because of high
taxes and blah blah blah
and shifts like oh well we're the
business friendly party and it's
meaningless what he's saying of course
but i wanted to kind of smack bill maher
through the tv and be like
what are you talking about you are the
one that's supporting all of these
people
and then all your friends leave and you
wonder why you're alone
well sometimes they don't even say we're
the party of they just go
well people are leaving because of over
regulation and high taxes
and a bad business environment it's like
yes they're leaving because of all the
policies you enacted those are your
policies
that's why they're leaving yeah they
seem to be unable to make that
that jump lockdowns i know you're not
happy you're as pissed as i am
you're tweeting about it all the time do
you think there's any
like on the science level do you just
think there's any science behind any of
this at this point there
i mean again right now we could both
walk out we live about 20 minutes away
from each other but we could walk
outside of our houses it's a beautiful
day as it always is
we cannot sit outside and have a coffee
because of lockdowns yeah
at a place where you purchase a coffee
yeah i think you could we could probably
go up to your roof deck you're always
welcome
actually i well you are welcome on my
roof deck but according to garcetti
you're not supposed to be on my roof
deck
oh right well a lot of it is you know
most of it is the crops are dying we
need a virgin to throw in the volcano
and someone goes how's that going to
help the crops and they go you shut up i
got to do something
the villagers are upset they want action
i mean whoever that the uh health
minister or or czar whatever of los
angeles
is much has admitted it's like i said
outdoor dining isn't dangerous we don't
have any data to support it's dangerous
but we want people to stay home you
literally said that you're not making
that up that is what the guy
said yeah well first things first
do you get to decide who stays home
that's your job
your job is i will decide when you get
to leave your house and even if it's
for spurious reasons and there is no
direct correlation between any danger
of spreading the disease and eating
outdoors i'm still just gonna make this
random decision and you shall stay home
i mean it's a very
it's funny it's a it's a comment that
kind of slid by a lot of people but
it's it's a very scary precedent
when the powers that be are essentially
saying
you're gonna stay home because i told
you to stay home
and then you go give me proof why i
should stay home and they go i don't
have to give you proof
i told you stay home but are you shocked
how
quickly we all became sheep i mean
everybody everybody
well what what what i realized what what
has happened
is california especially
los angeles especially it's so over
regulated
it's so burdensome it's so
it's so tyrannical and it's its leaders
are so tyrannical in terms of its burden
that they put on the taxpayers that we
all got sort of indoctrinated into this
slowly like imagine trying to pull this
[ __ ] off in 1955.
right people just be like uh no i'm not
staying home
and by the way i'm by the way when i
leave my house i'm taking my gun in case
one of you [ __ ]
tries to arrest me like that's where we
would be at but it was a slow
quiet indoctrination of i mean think
about
what you can't do here's what you can't
do
here's what you must do here's all the
things you know
you you can't smoke in a restaurant okay
well go to the smoking
no smoking oh then i'll go to the bar no
no smoking at the bar well then i'll go
the patio no smoke in the pan
like it's such a crazy um
stockholm syndrome that everyone lives
everyone who lives in california has a
kind of a stockholm syndrome
like i would say i say all the time hey
your business your restaurant
there's no reason why you need to shut
down your outdoor dining you've made a
lot of concessions you spent a lot of
money
just eff these guys stay open and
everyone's like i don't want to get into
trouble
well that's what the over-regulation has
created this this
this huge sort of umbrella
always you know under the guise of
safety
and everyone is just scared but but
slowly scared like
just think about think about
you know what think about the beach i
always talk about the beach but think
about the beach
like imagine telling someone from the
50s in malibu hey
you can't have that cigarette on the
beach what are you doing i'm drinking a
beer you can't drink a beer on the beach
i mean you look at the sign i always
tell everyone look at the sign
at the beach uh in the 50s they didn't
have a sign
at some point it was like no bonfires
between
3am and 6am you know now it's like no
frisbee
no dogs no football no cigarettes
no literally no humans no humans like
literally yeah no humans on the beach i
mean think about what
think about how they ratchet it up think
about how the sign gets longer
they always add something to the sign
they never remove something from the
beach sign every year there's two more
things you can't do
on the beach and when you go physically
look at those signs now
it is a scroll of things citizens
can't do on our beach if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about comedy instead of
the non-stop yelling you get everywhere
else check out our comedy playlist and
if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're both
right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell